as if there isn't enough going on in
westminster this week it all got a bit
double07 when mi5 issued a rare warning
about a chinese agent who had
infiltrated parliament and was
influencing current and aspiring mps
it meant some awkward questions for
labor's barry gardner and others and
left many mps already concerned about
china's activities calling for a harder
line
leading those calls this week was ian
duncan smith and he was of course leader
of the conservative party in the early
2000s at a time when the party also
trailed labor in the polls so he knows
plenty about the challenges to the
leadership he joins me now live from his
constituency good morning mr duncan
smith
if we can start with the
parliamentary issue
um mi5 had to issue an urgent alert
because of the activities of the chinese
agent affecting our parliament and that
established a link between the communist
party in china and current and aspiring
members of parliament now another week
we'd be talking about
nothing else pretty much but
um even in this week it's still pretty
shocking isn't it
it is and um the reality for us is that
i think successive governments have been
completely asleep at the wheel over this
issue
completely asleep at the wheel
and
the reality therefore is that we need to
figure out where we are with china
whether we have a relationship or
whether they are seen as a threat
if you look back at the foreign defense
report
you will see that they categorize russia
as a threat but china is a competitor
and it does then lead you to wonder why
that was the case and the answer is i
think that
china over the years has so dominated us
in a way that we are now completely
dependent on them for a whole series of
items and articles
they've got themselves into the position
of being able to invest into our nuclear
industry
most of the
solar arrays the elements on them are
produced by slave labor from xinjiang
the insides of most of the wind turbines
that we have are all made in china we've
become utterly dependent and far too
many officials and ex-ministers
have then left and retired and gone and
taken
money from china so
the very fact that they are in trying to
persuade and infiltrate
and subvert people within our political
system is nothing new at all but the
worst bit about it is the government too
many governments seem too
cautious about calling it out this is a
brutal dictatorial ghastly regime and we
seem to want to i think uh cow tower to
them too often and that's dangerous and
you've seen the results of that and this
is just the tip of the iceberg i can
promise you
i wonder if you could be clear about why
this is such a big problem because
politicians take donations from all
sorts of people don't they and
part of that undoubtedly must be because
those people want to influence those
politicians and
you know we elect we hope
independent-minded people who won't be
swayed why is this particular issue such
a big deal
well number one we're dealing with a
regime which is committing genocide we
are dealing with a regime that has
trashed a british sino-british
international treaty on hong kong we're
dealing with a regime that is locking up
peaceful democracy campaigners
and threatening taiwan we also deal with
the regime that has killed indian
soldiers on its border in disputes and
has taken over the south china seas and
has threatened everybody and anybody and
is now subverting countries in africa uh
you see the other day that if they don't
pay their loans back which they're given
i saw the other day i think it was in
sri lanka they've taken over a port
pretty much i mean this goes on we are
not dealing with a
a european regime or an american regime
which is democratic and accountable this
is a brutal disgusting regime and what
they're after is making sure there can
be no criticism of them so they can
break every rule that they wish and they
do
and therefore we won't and after all
let's just be reminded of one thing you
know covid19 kovit19 whether or not we
believe it came from a laboratory or not
you know the communist regime of china
refused to let the world know of the
scale of the problem they had until very
late on uh well over a month month and a
half
before they told officially the who by
the way the who
uh themselves seemed conflicted because
they should have been asking direct
questions but they didn't the result is
that has spread around the world so when
you're dealing with a regime like this
that doesn't tell the truth that doesn't
open up and is brutal then this sort of
thing you know millions have died as a
result of that so we can't just treat
the chinese government as any other
government you know so when they start
infiltrating when they start subverting
parliament and when they start paying
people off we've got to be much much
much more brutal about it and australia
shows us the way to do this which is to
ban uh in involvement with the uh the
chinese authorities and china
in critical circumstances well just very
quickly though
we've identified one individual uh
christine uh cinque li um
do you believe that there are other
people
doing this
oh absolutely certainly uh i think this
is the tip of the iceberg let's just
look at universities for example
in plain sight you've got the confucius
institute which uh offers to pay uh to
help students understand china in fact
what so much of it does is spy on
chinese students many of our
universities have become completely
dependent on chinese students i was
talking to one the other day that had
allowed members of the embassy to come
to one of their debates about china so
they could literally spy on who was
saying what i mean this goes on
everywhere you know if you look at where
their money goes whether it's huawei or
anything else you know it's all about
subverting us and making sure that they
can undercut
the bid contracts etc and win contracts
and win over the uk so it's very
important okay we recognize china as a
threat not as a competitor right forgive
me for interrupting you but i i want to
move on to of course the issue of the
day let me be absolutely straight
forward in asking this question
let's leave the
technicalities and even the kind of
small politics out of this um you've
done the job
do you think that boris johnson is
morally fitted
to remain as leader of the conservative
party
well one rule i always made for myself
is not to enter the world of morals i'll
leave that
to those
who practice and preach and deliver
religion and once a politician starts
yeah it's about morals
forgive me you will have been talking to
your constituents this weekend
completely different
it would be hard to imagine that that
question is not being asked
between them and
to you
well you know is it a morality question
or is it a question about whether or not
these things should have happened so
let's let's remove the two and just deal
with the reality this is unforgivable
there is no question that what has been
going on uh and despite your previous
interviewee has unearthed the culture
which has become lazy and slack about
what happens after hours what happens in
offices
you know most businesses wouldn't allow
what was going on in the offices even
though people have been under pressure
this was in the middle of lockdown with
oppressive rules uh about what people
could and couldn't do and there's no
question uh my constituents other
constitutions are quite rightly very
angry about the fact that many of them
were having to obey what some of us felt
were over onerous rules but nonetheless
they were rules
and yet there seemed to be others doing
things that they weren't able to do at
the heart of government
and maybe across government too in other
departments so the key thing here is
this was wrong there is no question for
it there's no there's no explanations
there's just apology and contrition and
we have to see now what sue grey comes
up with the extent of it
who was responsible and how it's all
worked
all right let let me take the word moral
or morality out of my question and put
this to you again because you've been
there
isn't this a matter of character
and isn't the danger here
that the character of your leader uh
is essentially
defining the conservative party and
potentially losing people like you with
your
not gigantic majority your seat
well as i said earlier on this is not an
issue about quibbling as to why or
wherefore this is about
understanding that responsibility always
uh in these issues comes to the heart
of it all and it's about the prime
minister's authority and about his
decision-making and whether or not he
knew or understood what was going on
is a question that sue gray will settle
but there's no question right now
that this is an appalling set of
circumstances it should not have
happened none of them should have
happened you know what i can't
understand is why there wasn't a sign
nailed up on every door of every
government department including downing
street that would have said simply when
you have finished your work go home
go home not stop by
that sort of level of understanding is
beyond me and not it out so absolutely
not i mean i'm as appalled as anybody
else i'm as appalled as my constituents
uh it's simply uh appalling one way or
the other part we have to see finally we
call for this inquiry let's see what it
comes up with and then we will make our
decisions give me
thank you very much ian duncan smith
thank you for your time this morning